hey guys so as most of you know we are
building out our home studio so I am
sitting outside right now doing a direct
message right off the top of my head
we've got a lot of cool stuff going on
we've got the walls built the floor is
going in tomorrow we've got lighting air
conditioning our cameras are getting in
there sound proofing should be ready to
roll in about a week or two but for this
week we are continuing our partnership
with learn Liberty which I love so far
we've had professor Randy Barnett from
Georgetown University we've had Steve
Davies from the London School of
Economics and this week we have Joanna
Williams from Kent university and the
editor of spikes online the education
editor of spikes online and we're going
to talk about education we actually shot
the interview already so I can tell you
that we did talk about education since
we don't have our studio my good buddy
Larry King and our friends over or a TV
lent us their studio for this and we got
to the ins and outs of education what
actually is education what is a
well-rounded education should an
education come from the government or
from a family or something in between or
from a community we talk about all this
stuff and you know it's so related
education in and of itself is so related
to everything else that's going on right
now because with all of this political
craziness between the election and Trump
and tweets and free speech and all this
stuff it all fits in that if you have a
well-rounded education when people come
in with easy answers well if you're
smart and you've been educated well and
you understand history and language and
politics and the rest of it then you
can't be swayed that easily and I think
right now what's happening in our
country is that we have so many people
who are so poorly educated that all
they're doing all the time is real
to nonsense from politicians and from
the media and all that but what we need
is a well educated populace that
understands how our electoral college
works that understands how the voting
process works how understands our basic
math works I'm not that good at math but
basic science all the things that
actually affect our lives that we learn
through a well-rounded education so
Joanna and I we shot the interview a
couple days ago and we had a great
discussion on what education actually is
and what the role of your family and
your friends and your community how it's
part of it and are there some things
that shouldn't be taught in school but
should only be taught at home I think
you guys are going to really dig it and
by the way education and this whole
conversation really is so locked in with
what's going on here you know the big
thing at the moment is Trump this tweet
about not burning the flag some people
are saying he actually was just trolling
Hillary and the Democrats because in
2005 she was co sponsor of a bill that
was going to call his fines and possibly
criminalize burning the flag so maybe he
is trolling everybody he's now getting
the left to defend free speech and free
expression which I'm really into right I
like that I don't know that we should
have patroller in chief we should have
the commander-in-chief and even if he is
just trolling them to ultimately get the
left to be more on board the side of
free expression which pretty meta and
that's some 40 chest right there even so
the idea that he would put out there via
tweet or however he wants to do it the
idea of that if you burn the flag you
could somehow be a criminal or something
like that or be fine I think that's
extremely dangerous so we're in
unchartered territory here but as I said
I just two weeks ago when I sat out here
and I did the video called don't freak
out about Trump there's opportunity in
order to me there is feelings on every
side on the
on the conservative side on the liberal
side on the progressive side the
regressive side the resume on the
centrist side there is a feeling that
something that there's movement here
that all of us are kind of trying to
figure out what's going on and figure
out how to proceed and who our allies
are who we have to try to to bring to
our side of the argument but you know
how you bring somebody to the argument
you bring them to the argument with a
well-reasoned than educated argument not
just with cries of racism and bigotry
and all that stuff and unfortunately as
it will come to no surprise all I've
seen the left really do since the
election is just double down on that I
thought maybe there was going to be an
interesting opportunity of reflection
I've seen some articles about it but I
haven't seen that put into practice
anywhere so that's why I think you're
gonna really enjoy this week because we
talked about education and it's it's so
indicative of about healthy society has
good education we need better education
around here I think that's what I'm
trying to bring to you guys a little bit
and all right so enjoy the interview
with Joanna Williams and then we're
going to be doing some more live streams
before the the studio built out and then
we got some great guests plan and I'm
psyched about what's going on here we go
you